huh I mean oh I'm joining hey I'm in I'm
in because you might because I'm voix
yeah yeah it's a request sent hi good
trying to get in this vehicle there we
go
[Music]
now we're okay we're all dead
okay I'm getting my own care I like
Bob's car and wait you try to hop in
here yep okay I'm in we're fine
everything's fine over here and the host
yeah I think it's just cuz there's too
many people playing for good good we're
good everything nope there's a place yes
Lee [ __ ] don't why trying to count
around this area
yeah plain didn't work out too good huh
Bob find a plane
just hold on hold on no [ __ ] keep
your stupid boat oh come on it was joke
it was a joke joke who's okay hold now
you think so no promises on how this is
about to go to knock someone out no
dollar ramp no it's a dust devil I think
it might be a little more than
oh that's fun oh wait wait wait hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
let me in a dog jump my enough hooking
I'm on my own
wait a minute I'm not in I'm not on
don't shout on grandmom no hang on door
shopping no I'm gonna buy no I've got
the box no oh oh I got the plane is
working much better with the controller
this would be way better with control
controller for that what you're right
actually
nah that's for lames bring it in for
landed coming in I got a bird's-eye view
come in thank you yeah I'm gonna try the
controller okay okay here I come
oh my god tumbleweeds hurt like hell
oh my god guys the airplane is so much
better with a controller I am often
right
why is my sensitivity so low and I need
to change the setting anyone need a ride
in my aeroplane all right wait get hop
in all right good here we go first
what oh you really got a handle on that
[Laughter]
I'm cut no no no you want to ride rides
coming in with a ride rides coming in
rides coming in coming in fresh seasonal
and stable you want the ride ride ride
baby ride I landed it waiting hobbit
this is absolute pain okay we're gonna
go
oh my god I'm not even pressing anything
oh I landed on an island oh yeah I want
to do this geez there are some sick
tricks that I can do I can land on this
needle cut off Bowser see see gold my
way inside Wow now I'm standing on it
I'm not even holding on for all right
[Laughter]
hold up wait wait okay I'm holding on to
the other side yeah I guess I guess okay
here we go okay shot is thoroughly on
here and Marcus one is double handing it
wait what's up their butts on top of the
mountain to the Latin oh you you think
you're good enough to go to the mountain
what about me to Olympus I'm just kind
of hard to turn
[Music]
[Laughter]
bungee jump off the bridge oh I'm being
flirted with very hard I have the best
view from my room I doubt you could
afford the room I'm staying in well all
right that's holy God oh my god Jesus I
didn't turn into bread yeah where's Bob
Bob disappeared for a bit I feel like I
deserve this Jamie does happen imagine I
want to see top of the mountain
well Bob wouldn't take us at the top of
the moon Bob said we weren't worthy do
not run me up I am stuck I'm stuck
Oh God hello we have learned nothin and
gained nothing yeah pretty much that
sounds like something we would do oh
okay I'm on someone yeah grab grab us
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's fine okay go oh I know I told you
[Music]
I'm sorry
Oh up fire but I don't think I'm the DHS
I might go aha Thor's hammer I feel like
this is a barrel of gunpowder
hey barrel this is epic wait come here
wait yeah just just hit me well for
standing 5 feet away from Oh God there
you go Oh dudes zip my karate that's
a--fun can we come all the way up here
for the zipline is that why we're here
that's the one I want to get hot-air
balloon to way into the into the okay
are you going between two butt cheeks
that are farting is that what I'm
looking at down there yep come on damn
I'm come on straight I'm coming see if
you can land in it I couldn't I don't
want to land in it why would I want to
land into the fermented butt hole I'm
landing in this fermented ass Wow okay I
got it everybody on okay everybody get
on the fun motor on I got you waiting up
for me
you don't even worry about it
my friends read the deal okay don't
throw the needle the needle this is
great stuff just follow the road who's
farting your uber has arrived damn
pretty good
oh yeah grab the back grab the s grab
the S what's on the other mountain hmm
sure sure sure sure sure why can't we
ever do anything fine now I'm getting
this other plane if anyone wants to go
for a ride on a non fart flame I would
like Mountain it's [ __ ] hard enough
to do anything anyway it didn't never
affect you is only not good marquel I
ain't going nowhere
Oh what the hell you just play normally
holding hands I'm not grabbing he's
grabbing look it's wait it's not me okay
[Music]
you missed the box where just wrap the
goddamn handle it's right there it's not
grand man it wants its lock so bad oh my
god the actual the actual game part of
this game is so frustrating what get the
box oh my god just get in the thing in
the control someone decided to go so
quickly that there wasn't even the
chantry to hold on to the plane I think
you guys needs a couple therapy there's
a plane here
oh that's wonderful ah but you know I'm
out of time you know I gotta go really
sucks and wish wish I could stay with
you Wade he doesn't only my wife is
happy to spend time with me ah man
that's great for you I'm working look at
this juicy ass I don't want to look at
that juicy yes I don't want to
[Music]